right about now for many it means
working from home that is the new normal
and CBS News contributor Derek Thompson
has been doing that on and off now for
about seven years
he also wrote an article about it the in
the Atlantic it's titled the coronavirus
is creating a huge stressful experiment
in working from home that's definitely
true Derek good morning I know a lot of
people I swear they are productive when
they work from home and they are but one
entrepreneur told you that it's just not
a good idea and not effective for most
companies is that because of the fridge
of the couch and the television yeah I
mean I think in general when you think
about the benefits of remote work it's
you want to leave the good the bad stuff
about the office at the office and take
the good parts of the office home so a
good part about the office is that you
have routine the office is not your
couch you have to leave your couch and
go to the office in order to work and
that sort of division between work life
and leisure time is really difficult to
import back to your own living room your
own kitchen counter your own bedroom
it's especially difficult right now I
should say during a pandemic when you
have schools canceled the kids are home
the restaurants are closed so it's a
very different situation right now that
you might typically have but
theoretically that's the that's the
benefit of remote work is that you have
time to focus on your own you have time
to structure your time as you want and
managers aren't judging you by the proxy
of how often you are sitting in your
seats rather when you work from home you
can set explicit goals and they can
judge you by what you actually achieve
and what conversations should managers
and employees have with each other
before they before they start working
from home I talked to a lot of
researchers in the last few days really
the last few weeks about our sort of
brief was remote work future here with
the pandemic and two words kept coming
back to me information in isolation they
said the office at the office you have a
lot of information and you have low
isolation you're surrounded by people
you can see what they're like when
you're home however you have less
information about your co-workers and
you feel more isolated so I think what's
really important for managers and
workers to get right to make remote work
work is they have to over communicate if
you're getting up and you're going for a
walk let that person know if you want to
have a conversation with your boss don't
just make it a 10
to make it a slack maybe actually see
their face so you can see their
expression when you give them an idea
and they say whom I need to think about
that you can see exactly what whom I
need to think about that means when
people just type hmmm I have to think
about that you might just initially
think wow they dislike me they're
criticizing me but when you see
expressions in people's faces you
realize that emotions are more
complicated so Derek a lot of a huge fan
of video conferencing yeah there are a
lot of people who are doing this for the
first time we're really stressed out
about it I mean I've got a wife who's a
teacher who's suddenly at home she's got
to set up a classroom from home I've got
a daughter who's a researcher whose word
basically about being alone a lot and
loneliness is an issue in this isn't it
lonely this is a huge issue yeah I mean
that is again a word that just kept
coming back to me when I was talking to
people when I said what's the most
surprising thing you have to tell me
about remote work experiments that
you've seen other companies try that
kept saying the most surprising thing is
the loneliness factor it's the isolation
and of course that's going to be so much
worse in a pandemic when you're not
allowed to leave your house in many
cases you know if you look around the
world in places like Italy in Spain
maybe increasingly in places in the US
or it becomes really difficult to do
anything outside of your own home you're
gonna have real isolation real
loneliness problems and I do think that
as long as we're evaluating the degree
to which remote work works we need to
separate what is specific to the
pandemic and what is specific to remote
work specific to the pandemic you're
gonna have a lot of extreme loneliness a
lot of forced child care at home in
remote work generally the schools are
going to be open restaurants will still
be serving food you can go out and work
at a cafe and so you want to keep those
two issues separate you're pointing out
really good distinctions Derek so what
do you do to make it as stress-free as
possible I think about two things I
think about routine I think about
physical activity so again with routine
I've written a lot for the Atlantic
about how the boundary between work and
leisure was already becoming extremely
porous once you're working from your
couch and your couch is where you watch
Netflix and where you talk to your
manager and where you write articles
that boundary between weakened at work
and leisure it completely falls apart so
it's really important I think to set up
routines what are you going to
accomplish in the morning how are you
gonna take breaks when are you gonna
stop working and then physical activity
you know you're
go crazy if you don't do anything inside
if you just keep sort of pacing between
the refrigerator in the kitchen counter
and so trying to throw the little bit of
physical activity into my day is a
challenge but one that I try to do
yeah the walk near the fridge doesn't
count there we appreciate you coming
into the studio for us we'll let you get
home now I guess thank you thank you